That jacket is tough. You got the
Jordans on, too.
>> Oh, he's proud of us.
>> Oh, man.
>> You ain't no ball. I need that
[laughter] more.
>> What you wanted me to prove is Jesus was
Muslim. All right.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay.
>> I got one question.
>> Was Jesus one who submitted to the will
of God?
>> Yes,
>> he was.
>> Yes. Okay,
>> real simple. Do you agree that Jesus was
the one who submitted to the will of
God? Whoever believe that, raise their
hand.
>> We all believe it.
>> We all believe that Jesus submitted to
the will of God, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> What does Muslim mean?
>> One who submits their will to Muhammad
and Allah.
>> That's not the truth.
>> Oh,
>> see Muslim means one who submits to the
will of God.
>> Which which God Muslim?
>> No. No, it doesn't. That's all. You
arguing about it. I just prove it.
>> Well, we we we got to we got to talk
about it.
>> We got to
>> No, we got to we got to talk. We got to
talk. So, you said that a Muslim is one
who submits their will to God. Yes.
>> Okay. So, if I say that I submit my will
to God, but the God I'm talking about is
a statute in my backyard. Am I a Muslim?
>> Well, no. Because see, in the Ten
Commandments,
>> it said, "Thou shall not commit
idolatry." I D O L T. Idolatry. Hold on.
Right. I'm with you.
>> Now, idolatry is worshiping anything
that has a molecular structure. Sound,
right? Water, everything, right?
Anything that has a molecular structure
that's incompassed by 360 degrees of
direction.
>> Can I come in here? So, I'm I'm with
you, right? So, you cannot you cannot
worship an idol and say that you are a
Muslim, right? So being a Muslim is not
just submitting your will to God because
somebody can believe that their God is a
God, right? But you got to submit to
what Islam teaches God is. Correct.
>> What is Islam?
>> Well, that's I'm I'm surrendering to
Allah specifically.
>> Surrendering to the will of Allah. A
Muslim is one who surrenders to the will
of Allah. Islam is submission or
surrender to the will of Allah.
>> I got you. So now if I say I submit my
will to a statute or anything like that,
that's not Allah, right?
>> No, sir. Allah, not a statute.
>> We're good. So then there's a specific
concept of Allah that we have to have
and surrender to in order to be Muslim.
Is that right?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Okay. Good. So now what you need to
do is not just show me that Jesus
submitted his will to God. You have to
show me that he submitted his will to
Allah specifically.
>> To Allah specifically.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Yeah. I've been Muslim only 30 years. I
used to be a Christian. I used to be one
high. You be your one.
>> But notice you're you're about to show
me a verse where Jesus says that there's
one God, right? Who is that God he said
is one. Who is that?
>> I already went through that when I
recited it from the
>> No, you didn't because see now you're
now you're mixing two things. You you
quote the Quran where it talks about
Allah is one. He doesn't begin nor is
begotten. There's nothing like him in
creation, right? This is who you
described Allah is to be in the Quran.
Now, what you need to do is is you need
to show me that when G the one God Jesus
believes in is the same God that you
just described in the Quran. Like for
example, it says he doesn't beget nor is
he begotten. Right.
>> Oh, I see what you Thank you.
>> Hold on then. I got you.
>> So, who does Jesus say his God is?
There is no God except that one God.
Mark 12:28 and 29.
>> Who is that God, brother?
>> That God is the everliving. Is God ever
living?
>> Wait, is that what Jesus said?
>> Hold on. Listen, brother. We going to go
through that.
>> Okay, that's what I'm asking. Which one?
>> That's what I'm asking. Which one are
you talking about? The one in the Quran.
Is God a father?
>> No.
>> Okay. So the Jesus that the God that
Jesus speaks about in Mark 12 is his
father.
>> Okay, hold on.
>> So he's not talking about Allah this
Christmas.
>> It's over, brother. It's over.
>> Come on, bro.
[laughter]
>> I bet you you don't even know what it
what it means for him to be the Messiah,
brother. You don't even know what that
means.
>> The Messiah.
>> What does that mean?
>> Jesus going to come back and slay the
Antichrist, bro.
>> But what does that mean to be the
Messiah?
>> Jesus is the word of God, brother.
>> What does that mean? You hear me? Jesus
is the word.
>> Is the word of God created?
>> He going to come and slay the
antichrist.
>> Brother, did you did you want to try?
>> Can't be Muslims if we don't believe.
>> We don't He failed.
>> Standing out here
having some interfaith dialogue. So
naturally,
>> cops show up.
>> Are they with you over there?
Pink handcuffs.
>> Pink handcuffs.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, no one came out of here
and complained about there was one There
was one dude uh who and he just left. He
was upset. We he actually engaged with
us and had a conversation. It was fine.
Okay.
>> But he didn't he was like, "Man, y'all
not about truth. I'm going to get y'all
kicked out of here."
>> All right, guys. So, we just had an
awesome experience. A guy attempted to
give us some da da da.
>> Tried to give us some da. And what
happened was he tried to prove that
Jesus was a Muslim after getting
absolutely destroyed and embarrassed in
front of all the crowd he drew. He then
he then called the cops. [laughter] He
called the cops on us and left. So, he's
been watching us this whole time. Ended
up leaving once he saw the cops were
here. And uh the cops just came and
talked to us. It was a good time. They
said, "Oh, yeah. You're not bothering
anybody. Just keep doing what you're
doing." Uh, but it goes to show you this
is it's double-edged sword. You talk to
us, you get embarrassed. You don't talk
to us, you're cowards and you're
running. But you talk to us, you get
embarrassed. What you could do is you
could call the cops. You know, hopefully
they take us away or something. You
know, let's try to inconvenience them as
much as we can since we can't beat them
intellectually. That's da guys.
>> Y'all come over here. Y'all ain't going
to say no to the Jews. They the ones
[laughter]
here about Jews
>> and he he's the one going and gathering
information on people.
>> Let me get their license plate. Let me
get their license plate cuz cuz they're
CIA. I think
>> Hey, we got MSAD agent here.
>> We got Msad out here spying on
everybody. [laughter]
>> Look, we got MSAD. He's a MSAD agent. He
was going around taking pictures of
everyone's license plate. He covers up
his own [laughter] because he's from cuz
he's working for Msad.
>> Hey guy. Hey, this dude's a MSAD agent,
man.
>> This is how Christianity do.
>> Yeah. Unlike slaughtering people in the
name of Allah.
>> Yeah. Who do that? That's what the
Christians do. That's what the Clu clan
do.
>> That's what Muhammad did.
>> The Clu clan are the original.
another black man.
>> Come on, man.
>> Black.
>> I ain't black.
>> I ain't black. I ain't none of that.
What you talking about?
>> Your own people, man.
>> Oh, man.
>> USE A TRAITOR TO YOUR OWN PEOPLE, DOG.
>> That's right.
>> No, use a trailer. HEY, THIS THE TYPE OF
ONE THAT WILL BE INSIDE THE HOUSE WHILE
WE WORKING IN THE FIELD.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THESE THE TYPE OF ONES THAT WILL GO
AHEAD AND LICK HIS MASSIVE BOOT. THAT'S
RIGHT.
>> CALLING [screaming] THE MASS ON HIS OWN
HOMIES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HE'S THE ONES WE GOT TO CALL OUT.
[screaming]
>> IS THAT THE TRUTH?
>> THAT'S THE TRUTH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HOW YOU THINK YOU WANT THEM PROUD OF?
>> HE WAS HE WAS BREAKING BOOTS.
>> SELLING OUT.
>> That's some crazy boots.
>> That's right.
>> IT WASN'T ALLAH. ALL OF THAT BLESSED
YOU, HOMIE. [laughter]
>> [laughter]
>> That's crazy, man.
>> I never thought this would happen, man.
>> I thought I COULD TRUST YOU, MAN.
[laughter]
>> Look at your skin color, man.
>> You look like me.
YOU LOOK LIKE ME, MAN. I thought I could
trust you, man.
>> I GAVE YOU A CHANCE, MAN.
I GAVE YOU THE CHANCE TO PROVE THIS,
MAN. TO BE UP ON THE HOP. BE UP ON THE
TRUTH.
>> BE UP ON the truth. That's right. That's
right.
>> BUT YOU LIED.
>> BUT YOU SNITCHED.
>> AND HE SNITCHED.
>> HE SNITCHED.
>> He snitched on THE WILL OF ALLAH.
>> COME ON.
>> That don't make no sense. Player
>> I loved you, MAN. [laughter]
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> YOU LIKE MY OLD SON.
>> YOU WAS LIKE A BROTHER TO ME, MAN.
[laughter]
HE WAS MY BROTHER. MY BLACK.
>> LOOK AT THIS MAN. [laughter]
>> Look at this.
>> Look at this man. Never never make a
>> Now LOOK AT HIM. LOOK AT HIM. Now look
at me. THE SAME. YOU THOUGHT I WAS OVER
THERE, didn't you? [laughter]
>> Look, man.
>> That's the picture of Dawa, man.
>> That's what DA looks like, man.
>> Da da is nothing but inconveniently
harassing you and snitching.
We know a snitch, don't we, David?
>> We know what was like.
>> It's one of Malik's disciples right
there.
>> Malikipalik. [laughter]
>> Who did it?
>> Who didn't?
Who? Who? He just backfired on me. Who
that? Who on that? Who on that? He just
backed [music] on me. This is a powerful
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.